people are feeling romantic about
nationalization because they don't
remember how awful it was their railways
and natural monopolies you don't get to
choose which train you travel on which
company you choose it doesn't make sense
to introduce a market into the railway
there are two big problems with the
railways at the moment the fares are too
high
and they've been going up relentlessly
and the second problem I could put into
words southern rail if you look at some
of the trains they've invested in
they're pretty unpleasant no tables no
it's put your drinks down looks like the
sort of place they want to hose down off
the passengers have been in there Ising
privatization has brought many advances
certainly one of the advisors brought is
an enormous increase in the number of
people using trains Jeremy Corbyn is a
great train spotter so he and I see
completely eye-to-eye in the railways
and I'd love to be his thing controller
but we didn't feel it appropriate to say
that Chancellor in the transport
secretary were locked in mortal combat
but that is more or less what aboard
[Music]
Britain is the birthplace of the modern
railway but the network is now at the
center of a political battle 25 years
ago every train every piece of track and
every station in the UK was sold off to
private companies now it calls for reen
actualization growing louder we're here
to ask why did we privatize the railways
and was it worth it one man who is there
in the engine room of the great
conservative sell-off stoking the fires
of privatisation is now better known as
a connoisseur of the railways
trains were old they were very often
dirty and the most famous symbol was the
curly British Rail sandwich because the
standard of a finger support so it was
universally acknowledged that the
nationalized industries were giving an
extremely poor standard of service
because they had no accountability to
the customer the private railway
companies were taken into public
ownership in 1948 when Clement Attlee
Labour government decided to nationalize
swathes of British industry by the time
John Major became prime minister in 1990
the service was seen as a neglected part
of the transport system ministers
thought British rails management was
asleep at the wheel
and looked at ways to bring in the
private sector
why did the rail privatization come
quite so late I think it's partly
because it was complex and partly
because I don't think Margaret Thatcher
particularly wanted to do it I mean it's
not because privatization is much
associated Margaret Thatcher and
rightfully so although she moved into it
a little reluctantly
she was quite slow to do the first
privatizations and railways and the post
office for example were way down her
list so it only got going in the major
years and even then it took a very long
time and I when I was first working on
privatization the plans we had were not
at all
the plans that turned out to be quite
honestly the principal motivation was
that we had an industry that we thought
was in terminal decline and something
almost anything had to be done about it
and and this is really when I would ask
you to judge privatization against I
know there have been many other changes
but not many people gave railways our
hope even a survival in the late
nineteen eighties the railways more than
survived but the journey has not been
smooth
awarding contracts at the lowest
possible cost has depressed the quality
of train services the companies complain
of squeezed profit margins but
passengers still seem to blame the
operators as the government piles more
of the costs on to the traveling public
as passenger fares of risen so is public
anger and the remedy that these angry
commuters seem to be reaching for is to
take the whole system back into public
ownership one commuter decided he'd had
enough David Boyle challenged southern
rails poor service by organizing a
protest at Brighton station with his
fellow passengers
they were irate at the delays and
cancellations resulting from an ongoing
dispute between the train operating
company and the trade unions they
refused to show their tickets and had a
tea party instead well the reason I got
so cross was during the strike where no
one was taking responsibility for it
because it felt like you're going into a
restaurant they won't give you your meal
properly they're late and delivering it
makes still expect you to pay and what's
more they say check your ticket they
have the nerve to check your ticket so
it seemed to me what would Gandy do in
those circumstances he would refuse to
show his ticket it's a ripoff for both
passengers and the public and it has
failed that's why we need public
ownership Kat Hobbs speaks for we own it
a pressure group campaigning for public
services to be brought back into
government hands 76% of us believe the
railway should be in public ownership
and that's across all age groups you
know we know that people really believe
the railway should be publicly owned and
we can achieve that very easily by
bringing rail franchises in-house as
they come up for inure when you see the
ridiculous chaos in southern railways
and the huge inconvenience to the
travelling public going back several
months
well of course from the public our title
not just to be annoyed but to be very
very angry if I used southern Rio be I'd
be livid at the nonsense that's gone on
there
another angry protester actually this is
Malcolm Rifkind former transport
secretary and one of the architects of
Britain's privatize railways I basically
reversed what was perceived to be
conservative policy of the previous
twelve years and said I'm ashamed a part
of a government that is committed to an
expansion of the rail network and I had
John Major's full support in doing that
when you were secretary straight for
transport
you were not in agreement with the
Treasury on how it should be done
although I had no problem with the
principle of privatization where I did
depart from the view of the Chancellor
of the Exchequer and of the Treasury was
as to the separation of responsibilities
for the infrastructure for the railway
track from the operating of the railways
that used that track to divorce from the
person who's running the railway the
ability to manage this track as well in
the most economic and sensible way was
irrational
bad economics and bad business sense
instead of pushing British Rail into the
private sector as a single company it
was broken into three components track
rolling stock and train operators the
real competition on the railways was not
from other railways it was from whether
people decided to use the rail or to use
air or Road in order to get to where
they wish to go and that meant that by
the time of the 1992 general election
when the manifesto was being drawn up we
had not yet reached a position on this
in 1992 a secret memo was circulated
among senior conservatives discussing
how to privatize the railways the
preferred option was to approach
privatisation on the basis of line of
route why because this was easy to
explain and was appealing to local
regional pride and a sense of identity
that memo acknowledges that this method
would not be the most Pro competitive
solution opinion polls showed that
privatizing BR was popular with the
public it would be important to bring
about privatisation in a way that
captured the political trick
if it meant you were adopting a system
that in all other respects was an
inferior one then that would be a very
bad thing to do if you devised a policy
which not only appears to be the best
way of running the country but happens
in addition to be quite popular yes we
plead guilty as politicians to being
attracted to that as a way of resolving
whatever the problem might be but now it
seems that the pendulum of public
support has swung completely in the
other direction and favors the Labour
solution I think the public mood is
there absolutely they're saying bring
our railways back into public ownership
clearly in your view it would be a
mistake to follow the Jeremy Corbyn John
one of the silliest was foolish things
they could do apart from anything else
it would cost billions of public
expenditure there would be massive
disruption for a number of years as
until you got backed and where would you
be going back to you'd be gained back to
a state system of running the railways
which during the period that it operated
in this country saw a constant decline
in railway usage and a constant increase
in public dissatisfaction right up to
all the 1990s when we privatized that's
what you called done there's no question
that passenger numbers have gone up
since the railways were privatized the
number of journeys has increased from
761 million in 1995 to 1.7 billion in
2016 but most of this is concentrated
around London not everyone thinks this
is fair I'm Lillian Greenwood I'm the
Labour MP for Notting himself than I
chair the commoners Transport Select
Committee
we're here on this train speeding and
community or constituency in not again
and clearly there's an enormous amount
of investment that has gone into the
railway system I mean you could always
say the railways have never had it so
good there's a lot more public money
going in there I look down the walls at
the time when we had British Rail as a
nationalized rail industry I think
that's one of things that perhaps you
know is a concern about franchising on
its own terms it was mentally to cheaper
fares more efficient railway like
requiring less taxpayer subsidy and
actually those things haven't been
delivered so how much money does the UK
government spend subsidizing each of the
train companies well it depends between
2016 and 2017 all of them received more
funds than they contributed to the
government with two notable exceptions
Virgin Trains East Coast and South West
Trains South West Trains lost its
franchise and Virgin Trains East Coast
has been flirting with collapse
[Music]
we ended up taking a system and throwing
it into the air with the infrastructure
pushed off into rail track a privatized
infrastructure company losing lots of
the engineering and expertise we have
the train operations put into 25
different franchises many more than
there are now and of course the rolling
stock that sold off to the rolling stock
apparatus
so basically broke our rail industry up
I think essentially rail track failed to
properly maintain the railway so routine
maintenance wasn't been done which led
to a succession of fatal crashes and it
was the failure of a privatized operator
to keep the network properly maintained
and to keep people safe that was an
absolute disaster I mean now we have the
safest railway in Europe that's
something to be proud of but I had to
come back into the public sector for
that to happen some veterans of the
labor government in the 2000s who Reena
lized rail track to create Network Rail
now believe that creating more
state-backed bodies could be the answer
there should be competition for
franchises between public and private
companies after we have state companies
in France Germany the Netherlands and
other countries who can compete for
contracts here what we don't have is
domestic state companies or not
for-profit companies that can compete
there's a lot of nonsense spoken since
all of the track and most of the
investment that goes into the network is
public investments we don't have a fully
privatized railway in any event over the
last decade the private sector has
invested hundreds of millions of pounds
into the railways each year but the
amounts invested by government can be
measured in billions yearly it's not
true
is not a true market or true competition
it is to some extent pretend capitalism
because the railway operators are always
going to receive subsidy so is the
supplier of the tract and the
infrastructure but that isn't the end of
the story because you can have different
franchisee seekers competing with each
other to see whether they can offer a
good standard of service for a lesser
subsidy it's a kind of negative option
other words that they are bidding for
the lowest subsidy sometimes it goes
wrong but on the whole it is not gone
wrong and those who underperform can be
replaced will be replaced have been
replaced at the end of the franchises
the reason why there's such support for
nationalization is because a lot of
private companies doing very badly but
either not running the trains like
southern rail or they're having to be
bailed out at taxpayer expense
like the East Coast you cannot justify
privatization unless the private sector
does a good job I mean I suppose people
do have short memories I suppose I'm in
a privileged position because I was in a
privileged position to remember how bad
things were maybe it's the case that
we'd have to go through the whole
wretched cycle again and learn the
lesson once more this nostalgia for
nationalized industries is absolutely
misplaced perhaps people ought to go and
dig out their old super 8 movies
and trying to report themselves what
life was really like nothing but wasting
our time the whole time been on the
train two hours this morning I never get
home till after half past 7:00 at night
we didn't arrive down here until three
course an hour late which means say we
miss our busses and we don't arrive home
until about an hour an important later
than we normally do whatever the
solution there have been some punch-ups
between commuters and railway staff
tempers have flared on both sides and
one local man was attacked with an
umbrella they used to be political
energy around the idea of privatization
we conservatives are returning power to
the people in the Thatcher and then the
major era privatization was meant to
give power back to the consumer but now
perhaps it means returning to state
control let's the next wave of
government transform threatened by
gently putting power in the hands of the
people power and Zia people
[Music]
you
[Music]